[Musik]
er soll es richten olaf scholz zieht als
kanzlerkandidat für die spd in den
bundestagswahlkampf
so soll es funktionieren
familienministerin giffey will
verhindern dass kitas wegen corona
wieder flächendeckend schließen müssen
wie geht es weiter in belarus proteste
und festnahmen nach dem zweifelhaften
wahlsieg von präsident lukaschenko
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
den nachrichten am heutigen montag und
auch norbert lehmann ist wieder mit
dabei für den sport einen schönen
eindruck von mir
mit ihm will die spd wieder ins
kanzleramt kommen heute morgen ist
finanzminister olaf scholz von seiner
partei zum kanzlerkandidaten ernannt
worden
mehr als ein jahr vor der bundestagswahl
wie schwer die aufgabe werden dürfte
lassen nicht nur die derzeitigen
zustimmungswerte der spd einen sondern
auch ein blick zurück bis 2005 war
gerhard schröder kanzler
seitdem konnte die spd keine
bundestagswahl mehr gewinnen
2009 tritt frank walter steinmeier an
die partei rutscht auf 23 prozent ab
2013 kandidiert peer steinbrück und holt
25,7 prozent 2017 kommt martin schulz
auf 20,5 prozent
und jetzt also olaf scholz aus berlin
berichtet andreas künast
bei der spd fängt heute mal wieder der
aufbruch an um 14 uhr 1 ist aus der
doppelspitze eine troika geworden und
aus olaf scholz nun doch noch die ganze
hoffnung seiner partei schon vor einem
monat sei die entscheidung gefallen sagt
scholz im kleinen kreis heute bestätigt
im großen im spd vorstand einstimmig und
deshalb ist unser ganz ehrgeiziges ziel
die nächste bundestagswahl erfolgreich
zu bestreiten und die nächste regierung
zu führen aber es ist auch unser ziel
dass dadurch zu machen dass wir die
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes und
auch sie hier
die journalistinnen und journalisten ein
wenig durch die von ihm unerwartete
geschlossenheit der sozialdemokratischen
partei überrascht die geschlossenheit
überrascht bei scholz für die
parteilinke
ein partei rechter ist seit er schröders
generalsekretär war im kampf um den
spd-vorsitz warf saskia esken scholz vor
kein standhafter sozialdemokrat zu sein
wir wissen auch dass diese entscheidung
für viele in der partei vielleicht auch
außerhalb der tat eine ungewöhnliche
wendung darstellt und gerade diejenigen
die wir überraschen
die möchten wir um vertrauen bitten in
diesen gemeinsamen weg
ob die spd ausschließen kann ein
weiteres mal in eine groko zu gehen die
antwort klar fast wir wollen die
stärkste kraft in einem von der spd
geführten regierungsbündnis werden und
das schließt wahrscheinlich deutlich
andere aus in der aktuellen groko hält
die union die entscheidung der spd für
so früh dass ich generell schlecht
findet daran über zeitpunkt und aussagen
ist dass wir jetzt bei jeder
entscheidung bundeskabinett sorge haben
dass das allein und der wahlkampf
gesichtspunkten steht offen muss olaf
scholz dass der betrugsskandal um
wirecard schnell aufgeklärt wird
ein untersuchungsausschuss könnte seinen
wahlkampf belasten
vielleicht zum schluss ich freue mich
über die nominierung
und ich will gewinnen die spd hat keine
mehrheit ihre gegner sagen keine chance
aber anders als alle anderen parteien
hat sie seit heute klarheit vor der spd
zentrale in berlin ist jack und anna
banerjee unter den parteivorsitz hat die
spd olaf scholz nicht zugetraut wie wir
sie ihren wählern eigentlich erklären
warum er kanzler werden soll er unter
anderem damit dass er großes vertrauen
und ansehen genießt als vizekanzler und
finanzminister das war auch im letzten
jahr schon so allerdings ist es in
diesem jahr noch mal ein bisschen anders
als herr über hilfs milliarden und auch
steuererleichterungen zieht er noch mehr
aufmerksamkeit auf sich in der korona
krise und das könnte einer der gründe
dafür sein warum die deutschen im
aktuellen politbarometer olaf scholz
gerade auf platz drei der wichtigsten
politiker sehen direkt hinter angela
merkel und markus söder
das wird sicherlich eine rolle gespielt
haben hier noch mehr als ein jahr bis
zur wahl so lange muss scholz also als
vizekanzler regieren und als
kanzlerkandidat der spd wahlkampf machen
ist das nicht eine zerreißprobe für ihn
ja das ist eine herausforderung er muss
jetzt in den dauer spagat gehen zwischen
weiter regieren und sich gleichzeitig
vom eigenen koalitionspartner abzusetzen
das ist noch mal schwieriger im amt des
finanzministers das eigentlich in so
einer koalition möglichst neutral
geführt wird so war es zumindest in der
vergangenheit das muss er jetzt über
zwölf monate durchhalten und hinzu kommt
dass an diesem unglaublichen langen
wahlkampf den daten jetzt durchstehen
muss ab sofort im auch alte sachen auf
die füße verhalten könnten der weiß kann
wirecard skandal etwa einer der größten
finanzskandale der deutschen geschichte
da könnte einen u ausschuss kommen und
dann wird sich bis weit in den wahlkampf
hinein eben die frage stellen welche
rolle hat olaf scholz dabei gespielt das
ist ein großes risiko
die spd nimmt das in kauf und setzt
heute sehr früh alles auf eine karte
vielen dank für die einschätzung bei den
neuinfektionen mit dem corona virus
zeichnet sich möglicherweise eine
abschwächung ab sowohl das
robert-koch-institut als auch die johns
hopkins universität melden im
tagesvergleich unter 500 ansteckungen in
deutschland im durchschnitt der letzten
woche schlägt sich das noch nicht nieder
demnach haben sich 870 menschen täglich
neu angesteckt gestern lag der wert noch
bei 840 die kitas flächendeckend zu die
eltern berufstätig das brachte in den
vergangenen monaten viele familien an
die grenzen ihrer belastbarkeit
heute begann das neue kita und auch die
politik hofft dass das ohne schließungen
über die bühne geht viel lust
händewaschen feste gruppen und wo immer
möglich abstand halten
all das soll einen normalen betrieb
möglich machen florian a
eine kleine kita in berlin-wedding 50
kinder eine frage welcher kroner regeln
können sie berücksichtigen welche nicht
der wunsch ist hier stabile gruppen zu
schaffen
aber angesichts des fachkräftemangels
ist das nicht einfach umzusetzen
auftritt der familienministerin
die vor allem eines erreichen will
stabilität
ein großes ziel nämlich dass ein heute
flächendeckende schließung von kitas und
kindertagespflege unbedingt verhindert
werden sollen
dafür nennt gefahr leitlinien eine
bessere hygiene masken nur für
erwachsene nicht aber für die kinder
veranstaltungen wie sommerfeste sollen
ausfallen
dem personal verspricht gefalle
kostenlose corona tests fielen die
kinder dürfen wie bisher auch nicht in
die kita ein leichter schnupfen aber sei
kein grund sie automatisch nach hause zu
schicken
für um- und ausbau von kitas steht der
bund eine milliarde euro bereit aus dem
konjunkturprogramm eine große studie
soll außerdem erforschen welche rolle
kita kinder bei der verbreitung des
virus wirklich spielen elterninitiativen
begrüßen die ansage der ministerin
fürchten aber dass bei krone ausbrüchen
vor ort trotzdem als erstes kitas oder
schulen schließen müssen
es muss bundesweit regelungen geben in
denen man sagt dass kita schließung das
allerletzte mittel sind und zwar ganz
unabhängig auch von dem allgemeinen
infektionsgeschehen es dürfen immer nur
die kitas geschlossen werden die
tatsächlich von einem chor oder fall
betroffen sind betroffen sondern diese
berliner kita übrigens bisher noch nicht
hier hofft man dass das auch im
regelbetrieb
so bleibt auch das neue schuljahr hat
begonnen in drei weiteren bundesländern
aber mit unterschiedlichen coroner
regeln in berlin müssen schüler und
lehrer maske tragen auf fluren und den
aufenthaltsräume auch in brandenburg
soll das landesweit pflicht werden
in schleswig holstein dagegen gibt es
nur eine dringende empfehlung für
schüler und lehrer einen mund nasen
schutz zu tragen
auch im unterricht nach belarus und der
umstrittenen präsidentschaftswahl
offiziell gewonnen hat amtsinhaber
lukaschenko doch es gibt massive
betrugsvorwürfe
rund 80 prozent der stimmen soll
lukaschenko bekommen haben
die oppositionskandidatin sich allofs
kaya erklärte dagegen sich selbst zur
siegerin
gestern abend demonstrierten tausende
gegen die wahl die polizei griff hart
durch
die eu kritisierte dass heute scharf und
forderte eine genaue auszählung
der stimmen christian senn berichtet
wenn alexander lukaschenko das recht
nach seinen maßstäben durchsetzt sieht
das so aus
jagdszenen auf unbewaffnete
demonstranten in der nacht in belarus
sicherheitskräfte knüppeln sich durch -
es gibt verletzte das innenministerium
spricht von 3000 festnahmen landesweit
menschenrechtsgruppen von 300 protest
gegen eine offensichtlich manipulierte
wahl und die niederlage von svetlana
tier an oskar diese frau hat uns
hoffnung gebracht hoffnung dass wir
unsere zukunft irgendwie ausweiten
belarus ist aufgewacht für swetlana tier
an oskar war es ein ungleicher kampf
gegen den ewigen präsidenten lukaschenko
bei einer wahl mit massiven
manipulationsvorwürfen tausenden
festnahmen ausgeschalteten kandidaten
internationale wahlbeobachter waren bei
der abstimmung nicht dabei die 37
jährige wurde zur hoffnungs figur der
opposition
heute zeigte sie sich bereit weiter zu
kämpfen und rief lukaschenko zum rückzug
auf wir kennen das ergebnis nicht an
wir haben absolut gegenteilige
informationen wir haben offizielle
protokolle von vielen wahllokalen in
denen ich viel mehr stimmen bekommen
habe als ein anderer kandidat
beeindrucken lässt sich lukaschenko
davon offenbar nicht über staatsmedien
lässt er mitteilen
die demonstranten seien vom ausland
ferngesteuerte schafe und immer wieder
warnt er vor einer revolution wie in der
ukraine
diejenigen die es nicht geglaubt haben
werden es jetzt glauben jemand versucht
hier spannungen zu schüren
ich warnte davor dass hier keine meydan
revolution stattfinden wird
egal wie sehr es jemand will in diesen
minuten wollen sich die demonstranten
wieder versammeln die opposition sagt
sie sei bereit für einen langen protest
frage an für becker hat die opposition
nach dieser wahl noch irgendeine chance
sie scheint auf jeden fall fest gewillt
jetzt noch nicht aufzugeben im moment
erreichen uns die ersten bilder aus
minsk die leute versammeln sich und das
obwohl es in der stadt vor polizei nur
so wimmelt aktivisten berichten auch
schon wieder von den ersten festnahmen
die es gegeben haben soll
diese oppositionsbewegung die für freie
wahlen und für mehr demokratie auf die
straße geht es breit aufgestellt und
bekommt solidaritätsbekundungen
das ganz überraschenden ecken gestern zb
gab es das foto von soldaten die mit der
fahne der opposition sich ablichten
lassen und heute sollen würdenträger der
orthodoxen kirche an einem flashmob
teilgenommen haben
das sind bemerkenswerte einzelfälle die
der oppositionsbewegung sicherlich
hoffnung geben andererseits sehen sie
sich alexander lukaschenko entgegen und
der hat bisher noch jede protestbewegung
ausgesessen
er kann sich im moment der treue seines
sicherheitsapparats sicher sein
und er weiß moskau an seiner seite denn
hier mag es zwar immer mal wieder
spannungen zwischen belarus und russland
geben aber im kreml ist sicherheit
niemandem daran gelegen dass im
nachbarland eine friedliche
protestbewegung eine zu einem
machtwechsel führen könnt denn das
wiederum könnte die opposition in
russland dazu bringen neue kraft zu
bekommen und das möchte kreml ganz
sicher vermeiden
vielen dank frau becker nach der
verheerenden explosion im libanon tritt
premierminister die ab zurück und mit
ihm die gesamte regierung die ab
erklärte die explosion sei das resultat
der korrupten verhältnisse im land seit
tagen gehen viele menschen in beirut aus
wut über die katastrophe auf die straßen
sie machen die politische elite
mitverantwortlich für die explosion und
uli gack ist jetzt am platz der märtyrer
in beirut wird der rücktritt die
demonstranten den beruhigen nein ich
keineswegs ich glaube das nicht ganz im
gegenteil sie ebenfalls wieder die
demonstration gegeben einige hundert
haben versucht das parlamentsgebäude zu
stürmen sind von der polizei
zurückgedrängt worden
ich glaube solche aktionen die bringen
nichts mehr gestern hat der
premierminister parlamentswahlen
aussicht gestellt das hat auch nichts
gebracht abends wieder massive
demonstrationen gegeben das ist
irgendwie alter wein in neuen flaschen
und dieser trick der über jahrzehnte
funktioniert haben mag der funktioniert
eben nicht mehr die leute merken dass
ein innerhalb dieser regierung die jobs
genau verteilt sind je nach religion der
premierminister ist steht wenn er
zurücktritt wird innerhalb seiner
verwandtschaft klick wert anderer
nachfolgen es wird sich dadurch nichts
ändern es ist ein etikettenschwindel in
diesem land der die menschen nicht mehr
beruhigt sondern wahrscheinlich eher
zornig macht die einschätzung von uli
gack aus weroth vielen dank dafür
es gibt neun streit zwischen
griechenland und der türkei
dabei geht es um erdgas im östlichen
mittelmeer
ankara hat jetzt ein forschungsschiff
losgeschickt die crew soll in der nähe
der griechischen insel kastelorizo nach
erdgas suchen
griechenland kritisiert das als illegal
weil das gebiet eine wirtschaftszone der
eu sei der erdgas streit hatte das
verhältnis zwischen athen und ankara hat
zuletzt dramatisch verschlechtert vor
wenigen wochen hat peking das
umstrittene sogenannte sicherheitsgesetz
für hongkong eingeführt jetzt geht die
polizei offensiv gegen prominente
oppositionelle vor
so wurde vor wenigen stunden mit akne
ist eine der bekanntesten aktivisten
festgenommen
zuvor war der verleger einer der größten
zeitungen hongkongs jimmy lee abgeführt
worden
der 71 jährige medienmogul hatte
kritisiert wikinger aber das neue gesetz
erlassen um die demokratie in hongkong
zu unterdrücken und freunde berichtet
die zeitung apple daily berichtet live
über die durchsuchung ihrer
redaktionsgebäude sie gilt als die
letzte verbliebene china kritische
zeitung in hongkong dafür hat jimmy lee
gesorgt der verleger und führende kopf
der demokratiebewegung er rechnete schon
seit längerem mit seiner verhaftung denn
pekings machthaber zu kritisieren ist
gefährlich jetzt passiert es sagt er
der vorwurf geheimabsprachen mit
ausländischen mächten
es ist ein gezielter angriff auf
hongkongs pressefreiheit dabei lassen
sich die sicherheitskräfte gerne filme
zur abschreckung
sie haben kein recht meine sachen zu
durchsuchen sagte der journalist der
polizist unbeeindruckt macht einfach
weiter
journalisten weg ihre arbeit anzugreifen
ist eine ernsthafte bedrohung für die
pressefreiheit chemie war zwölf als er
vor den kommunismus floh sein leben lang
kämpfte er gegen chinas autoritäres
system das neue sicherheitsgesetze hatte
er als einen todesstoß für hongkong
bezeichnet seit das gesetz in kraft ist
werden viele köpfe der
demokratiebewegung verhaftet oder
angeklagt nun ist die presse dran
alles laufe gut sagt der leitende beamte
er wolle niemand von der arbeit abhalten
am abend der zweite schlag gegen die
demokratiebewegung die hongkonger
polizei hat die bekannte
bürgerrechtlerin disco festgenommen
chinas machthaber wollen endgültig die
kritischen stimmen mundtot machen
und jetzt zurück nach deutschland wo
weiter richtig geschwitzt wird weit mehr
als 30 grad hat es vielerorts und es ist
sehr schwül alles ziemlich anstrengend
und immer wieder kommt dann auch
ordentlich was runter wie hier zum
beispiel in rheinsberg in der nähe von
dresden
da sorgte ein heftiges hitzegewitter für
überschwemmungen und umgestürzte bäume
extremes wetter das erst mal so bleiben
soll ja nun zudem norbert und heute
startet ja die letzte finalrunde der
europa league
genau und zwar in nordrhein westfalen
die viertel und halbfinals sowie das
endspiel
die werden dort als ko turnier
ausgetragen alles ohne zuschauer heute
abend spielt in düsseldorf das letzte
deutsche team im wettbewerb bayer
leverkusen trifft auf inter mailand ob
trainer antonio conte oder toptorjäger
lukaku die stimmung beim 18 maligen
italienischen meister lässt sich
durchaus als beschwingt und locker
bezeichnen
dennoch demonstrieren leverkusens
verantwortliche zuversicht ich glaube
schon dass allein durch die tatsache wie
sie jetzt vizemeister geworden
der juventus turin das ist ziemlich
leicht favorisiert sind aber nicht mehr
wir haben eine mannschaft die die tore
schießt jedes spiel gegen auch jede
gegner also die möglichkeiten sind da
und in sachen lockerheit scheinen sie
ebenfalls mithalten zu können
da zeichnet sich ein schwungvolles
viertelfinale ab james ensor bleibt
nächste saison beim bvb und wechselt
nicht nach england das teilte dortmund
sportdirektor zorc heute mit außerdem
seinen vertrag schon im letzten sommer
bis 2023 verlängert worden
die bundesligavereine die wollten zum
saisonstart mitte september wieder vor
publikum in den stadien spielen
die dfl hatte dafür ja leitlinien
erarbeitet heute erteilte der
bundesgesundheitsminister den plänen
vorerst eine absage
es wurde viel gelobt dass fans zurück
ins stadion konzepte dfl keine gästefans
keine stehplätze kein alkohol
personalisierte tickets
doch die zuständigen gesundheitsminister
hat das nicht überzeugt in der jetzigen
situation während zuschauer auf den
rängen das falsche signal twitterte
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
ganz anders dagegen also für eine
geordnete rückkehr sprach sich der
sächsische ministerpräsident aus
die deutsche fußball liga hat sich sehr
viele gedanken gemacht sie hat ein sehr
verantwortungsvolles konzept aufgestellt
ich bin der meinung man muss ihnen jetzt
die chance geben diese sache zu erproben
die wege zum und vom stadion sein das
problem da gebe es keine kontrollen
auch deshalb waren sich die
landesgesundheitsminister einig dass wir
in dieser pandemischen lage es ablehnen
dass die stadien geöffnet werden für
zuschauern zuschauer
ende oktober will man die situation neu
beurteilen so lange bleiben die ränge
offenbar leer also bis dahin geduldig
abwarten
geduldig abwarten gilt auch fürs wetter
da haben wir es nämlich weiter mit hitze
und gewitter zu tun
mehr dazu gleich von katja honnefer das
war es von uns danke für ihr interesse
claus kleber erwartet sie um 10 vor 10
zum heute-journal und wir freuen uns
wenn sie morgen wieder mit dabei sind um
19 uhr einen angenehmen abend noch
tschüss
[Musik]
die narben meine damen und herren das
wird eine schwüle warme eine hitzige
woche und auch heute gab es ja schon
etliche gewitter nicht nur rund um die
mittelgebirge sondern zum teil auch
weiter im norden und auch jetzt am abend
und in der nacht gibt es noch kräftige
gewitter
die fallen lokal auch durchaus mal
heftig aus also mit hagel platzregen und
sturmböen und zwar hier zwischen der
lüneburger heide und der eifel
in der nacht sinken die temperaturen zum
teil nicht unter 20 grad das wird also
wieder oft eine tropische nacht
angenehmer sind die nachttemperaturen
hier zwischen dem bayerischen wald und
dem bodensee mit 15 bis 13 wenn es
nachts kaum abkühlt vielleicht hohe
wolken über uns liegen wenn wenig wind
weht und die luft dazu auch noch so
richtig feucht ist dann empfinden wir
die hitze als sehr belastend und so
warnt der deutsche wetterdienst schon
heute für morgen vor extremer hitze im
westen deutschlands und fast
deutschlandweit vor hitze ausgenommen
sind da die regionen am alpenrand und
auch an der küste
denn da liegen morgen die höchstwerte
bei 24 bis 29 grad das ist besser
verträglich als die 30 bis 36 grad sonst
morgen vormittag gibt es noch wenige
gewitter das entwickelt sich dann aber
am nachmittag zum teil wieder mit
unwettergefahr
besonders im süden deutschlands und
schwülwarm und gewittrig gebe es auch in
den nächsten tagen weiter schönen abend
noch